so your advice to jon jones would be
take the stipe fight
yeah i mean dude anybody's [ __ ]
advice to jon jones would be take the
stipe fight
what are you thinking i think you should
fight the i think johnson should fight
that champion that that's deeply i think
should fight francis and geno the
champion
okay but that's not a possibility
anymore so
why not because he doesn't want to take
the third one because they're they're
gonna book derrick lewis and then goner
so and then
like what what jon jones wants to do is
wait for the winner of derrick lewis and
in goner so that he's fighting for the
championship
and maybe we disagree george but i think
if he
does take the stupid fight and and he
can win it
then then he's earned everybody's
respect
he gets two fights you know like you can
like beat steep bay
now it's like wow you want that
heavyweight like this is this is crazy
like now we take you very seriously now
we
we're really paying attention now we
really even more want to see
you fight for the but why wouldn't izzy
fight the number two guy like why would
izzy go up and fight the champion right
away
i i believe if i if i'm john jones
because
this what we're talking about it's it's
that's what we're talking about it's
like chess game you know
yeah between because these these are big
these are
big important decisions that you make
and
you know because fighting there's no way
it's always a questions of odds
doesn't mean if you think you're going
to beat one guy yeah doesn't mean that
even if the odds favor you doesn't mean
that you're always going to win
and i think it would be a mistake for
jon jones to fight stephanie i think i i
not because i i believe john jones will
beat stephen
however while taking the risk of
fighting steepy
when you can wait and fight for the
champion if you can
and and collect to belt and then after
john jones is the greatest of all time
if he does that like man he can run run
up to the sunset
sunset is stuck will be as high as
like more higher than anybody ever
and the world another world will open
for him
you know as he retired he could do
whatever he wants
the problem is guys they hang hang there
in a sport for too long
they they they are considered the best
but they ain't there for too long so now
they're
there their stock goes down and they
retire
as their stuck are down so when they
retire the
the door does not open for them because
they're
they they're already broke you know what
i mean they're stuck is is
bad you know yeah so that's why you
should retire on top
you know not and everybody keep fighting
for different reasons
i do not like to fight personally i did
it because it
gives me my my life my freedom and i
love it
i never like to fight i never enjoy it
one second i
hate it not knowing if i was going to be
badly hurt or humiliated for me it's
unbearable
that's why i'm a big fan of you guys
what you guys do in the jackass movie
you guys are completely insane and doing
it for fun i wish i could be like that i
mean you guys are
completely insane i don't know i don't
do it for fun at all i do it for
attention
i'm an attention [ __ ] that is
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your
butthole yeah
yeah dude